[Musique]
allez fabrice des balcons en toi et tout
se passera bien puisque tu as fait en
fait tu fais des courses je n'ai pas ma
carte de fidélité en duos venir tôt plan
qualité
et portal on avait bien sûr et comme par
hasard bah oui il était seul on arrête
de faire le mariole vous me suivez s'il
vous plaît
pour que tous coûter plus paul cours
lassus report ou ne m'oblige pas à faire
une roulade
j'avais reçues le résultat du labo pour
le poireau avant d'aller ouais ça va
très vite
fabrice rends-toi aux autorités
compétentes en même temps il fabrice lui
et je crois que gérard notre fils puisse
grandir avec l'image de ce qu'il a
toujours été pour lui est-ce qu'il est
comme nous le papa de gérard nom patois
malawi louis j'aurais que tu dises à
gérard combien je regarde toutes ses
parties de ou non j'ai refusé de faire
avec lui excusez moi monsieur mais vous
êtes trompé de numéro
par contre pour le uno
dans un village de lozère il y en a un
parmi vous qui parle lozériens moi j'ai
un ami qui a fait la fac il sépare les
lozériens non c'était fac de sciences
j'ai peur et je suis content que
j'ai attendu attendu elle n'est jamais
venue moi même ça vous dérangerait de
chanter avec ning parce que vous casser
un peu la dynamique du départ en
vacances à 13 je ne la connais pas la
chanson
ça fait du stop et ça connaît même pas
les paroles des chansons
[Musique]